[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very excited to talking about rethinking
scientific discovery
we have parney on barakat a joining us
on the show hello hello everyone very
excited to be here thank you so much for
coming on the show super excited those
that don't know
Barney's background she's an independent
researcher focused on the physics of
intelligence and you can find the links
in the bio below Shannon labs down Co as
well as your Twitter profile
alright party let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions asked
where guess what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world oh boy the
direction of Ford my main interest is
like two main aspects one is have your
shaping science or innovation
perspective be thinking about which
we're going to talk about and the other
one is like physics of intelligence that
I'm also very excited about because I
think the way we are bounding ourself
has come from the idea of like like the
direction and like even people that can
have more new innovative ideas and
discoveries that they usually don't
think about and that's something I'm
very very excited about her about like
innovations and new ideas so when you
were young like who were you that got
you interested in rethinking the science
and innovation yeah I actually was like
really interested in I've physics and
like teleportation when I was younger so
that was like my main childhood dream
and I supposed to study physics access
to physics to study in Moscow State
University in Russia before I finished
my high school but my parents didn't let
me to go so I had like a long journey
until I ended up in the US I ended up
not a study physics I jerk off friends
from undergrad and I did like bunch of
their friend random things
and then one thing it was kind of like
that's more of like a recent because
after I was visited Iran when I was here
for a year I was seeing all the very
interesting like innovations and textile
happening like in MIT in like Harvard
and like other universities but they're
like those are very very saturated it
from like something like people are like
super excited they want to like know
like how they can do science and like
researching how they can access to like
informations and yes you have all the
old web webpage of university professors
that you kind of look at too and like
Wikipedia pages but that's something for
example when you are like having a
problem you don't know what is all the
most like reliable resources that I have
and that makes me excited to start my
first company which I was like working
on but generally I really think about
like science and scientific discovery or
innovation and broader perspective but
we have the whole innovations like it
shouldn't be founded only in university
and university labs and with like a very
well structured mechanism and that's
something I do like to change as one of
my life goal I have lots of life goal
but that's right even how do we do
exactly that how do we unbound
scientific discoveries and advances out
of just academic yeah so like if you get
the problem in science you can break it
down in many different pieces like one
of the pieces is about scientific
journal and quite now for example we
should have some sort of experiment like
I mean each day I felt they have their
own disciplines and then you kind of
like use like certain experiment your
journals is like have some certain like
timeline for the experiment that you
design a new proofing something but and
then in some sense like many of those
incremental some of them in depends on
the fill is more fundamental but you can
think about this in terms of the journal
like you can do like lots of innovation
in journal for example and just like
constantly
updating my innovations over my ideas
over it can be more much more
crowdsource like people like come
together and like bouncing off like
ideas and the other things like it's
bothers me Tomas is at the language of
like each fold is a very very specific
so if I'm like for example start reading
about neuroscience and when I'm reading
that like there's a class of like we're
cobblers I don't know but the core idea
is a lot simple and then you see like
the whole sets of books and like solar
science books which is like crazy like
interesting sci-fi books but they're not
really connected with science but there
are like very interesting ideas and how
I can concretize those ideas into actual
science so then I guess that's something
I think is missing or how can I borrow
ideas from like many different
disciplines but I'm not formulating like
ideas for doing that discovery that's
something you can like work on next
scientific journal and there's like a
whole branch of things like in the
incentive structure so like lots of like
scientists are thinking about like who
is going to be the first author and one
thing I really really care like
interested by few scientists and like
one of them is like Satoshi I guess like
it was okay anonymous independent person
that like I didn't say like he did like
a breakthrough discovery but he did the
structure that changed the whole like
market like significantly and
anonymously
I don't know mostly and that was like
something I think it linked they were
missing a lot in the science
selfless breakthroughs stuff exactly
Nick how you can kind of working on the
directions that are not a research that
is not based on any like academic fame
or based on any third stuff like aqua
Dacians like if the goals like is
discovered and it should be in like it
should not come from all like level of
things that when we do like science
especially not in
like everyone when they do like it so we
are the best organizations or we are the
best people doing AI because of X BCD
but there is like lots of like
manipulations over like how is that
controlling those like silence and like
discoveries and who is getting credit
for and you see like all those like
armies between those like systems and
what I'm interested in acting honestly
it is not an animus but like it's like
someone that is did like a huge impact
but he like think a lot less in terms of
like what is a part like who's going to
control like internet which that was
like a discovery that we have it's a
significantly change and that should
happen a lot in more different girls yes
not be lacking and then you have the
sets of like academic institutions I'm
not against academic institution I think
they provide like lots of tremendous
values that exist like you are in the in
talk show like like simulation
essentially that you can talk about like
gossip when they go off this people to
mentor you anak lots of professors but
there are different systems here that
you can questions about like why if I
want to do science why the ph.d program
should be three for four years why can't
I come ready and come back and why it
should be age I might come up with a
crazy idea when I'm like 65 and or like
twelve and I want to do science and yes
super - a can like talk with like
research but the structure is like not
very well designed when you trying to do
like innovation or when you trying to
like or if you want to work on many
different fields like you need to
provide your own credit in order to be
able to speak your ideas or direction
that you want and there's a whole
process of like matching with the first
one of macmost or a line like one of the
main problem I like to do science and I
have our time to find out exactly the
professors that really understand
can expect with them hours and hours are
talking about like ideas which might
shape like they were very like we do
things and I think that like connections
is like something missing with like
science and there is a whole set of
ideas also you can see like in terms of
like grant and funding and how much of
like those effect on the relationship
and I advicing veterinary students and
professors and like some of the times
like students they don't have
independence and they are like really
like bounded to particular like grants
money that exists that the project I had
to work or that the professor's going to
provide them and some it's unfortunate
but like some of the universities that
they are not able to get like lots of
the grant funding because it's based on
a creations then you last look at the
ideas you are like let's look at like
the innovation that comes through they
kind of let go to like a negative like
feedback loop and then the science a lot
become like more only segmented in like
a particular like areas and a query feel
like people are like extremely like
famous or they're like really good at
communicating like their ideas and
that's something and mismatch because a
lot of those ideas that we see like in
the papers are not very well article or
they weren't like in the labs or
professors they weren't very famous and
I think that's something and thinking
has been like lots of times like satsang
rush me he was like I don't know like
how he like how that structure I can be
a
replicatable were like there might be
some ethical there might be some ethical
considerations like I don't know exactly
but but he published like about Bitcoin
making like a random like black was
right and I grande the mailing list and
without any like journals or like things
and that was ready I guess like the hole
I was like very interesting to me and
dr. core community of people that could
keep going with the breakthrough yeah
and
he could remain anonymous or she or
whatever it is so I want to visualize
this together with you so in a sense
civilization has its edge of knowledge
that we've been pushing over and over
again in different fields over time and
the current way that we push the field
the edge of the different fields there's
incentive structures that give people to
push at the edge and there is also a
there's all these different variables
that go into how people decide to push
at the edge and so how do we make it
most effective for people to push at the
edge of different fields have transfer
learning have within we have lexicons
within fields that can easily transfer
ideas across fields yeah all these
different things come together for a
more cohesive scientific discovery
process so I think there are like few
process involve in that setting
Hwanhee is like a scientific tools that
we can work on and make it much like
better in order to build sets of system
that make those communications or
relationship between different fields or
ideas like much more interesting like
for example I mentioned to you that we
can create something like github that
people can push their ideas that
constantly or you can like simplify like
you can probably some make website like
doing a simplified versions of your like
using like language models that we
already have and they give you like a
simplified versions of like an idea but
those are like a sets of scientific tool
your potential connect work on acordes
so for example I had like for like
creating like a better visualizations of
like science that you like to talk about
but also the other things I'm
interesting you like lots of people like
FaceTime Irina Kevin also it like he was
like hey I'm like MIT Media Lab and he
posted his research like that he's like
interested to work on like publicly and
I feel like a lot of like professors
they should post their research and the
main question that we should ask where
important questions like publicly and
like lots of people that express
although they kind of like understand
that like like fragmented vision more
cohesive and I think those people need
to ask like more fundamental questions
in the science community and this
question should be published a lot more
and be more requests in terms of like we
are working on those like directions and
yeah because I think like right now when
you the process of mentor you're just
like doing a lot very incremental
changes especially like Seinfeld and
that's like one part I think like what
next sets up tool you make but making
the informations are most important much
we have a higher weights do you maybe we
can have the Canadian mechanism for
figuring out what types of questions or
like things I can like answer and how
does relationship between those ideas
come to and then I think the other
things also would be interesting is like
a coordination problems of between
different types of researchers that we
see are they are allocating the
resources for like sets of ideas and
neck right now is like whatever I can
market my ideas or I think I can solve
it is like become like it's like a very
poetic like science like it's like
philosophy boys a [ __ ] converge here in
like AI and I could go to like a bar
sonic everyone come ready for an effect
in like biotech like you kind of see the
scientific hub and so converging like
some directions because there's like a
lot more funding and there's like lots
of resources available there and I think
I'm not too sure what stands about the
questions like how we can kind of break
down those like symmetrical like
locations and like more fundamental
questions like Oh what are the faults
that might be or questions that we can
ask there are like like lots of
professors like in university thinking
about things like 30 years or 40 years
or like hundred years from now or like
maybe less like on different felt but
like tend to like we see those signs up
converging towards like a same
directions that like your sign
like creating like particle flavours FPS
episodically true like a time period
that we see and the question how we can
restructure that potentially in the it's
another one of the aspects that you've
been mentioning along so many of these
other key points is that when we do push
for scientific discovery what are the
motives because in this is a really good
way to view it and we're ending we're
gonna end up making a piece of content
on this down the line but this this the
Satoshi method of pursuing pushing the
edge of the field because when you
deploy updates to the rest of our world
and you do it in a way that's anonymous
you don't do it in a way that seeks Fame
and that seeks fortune but you do it in
a way that seeks to better the world and
you stay out of the vortex where people
can critique your personality and who
you are as a person rather than the idea
so that that in itself is such a I think
a major key people want to make
breakthroughs in science but then all of
the perverse incentive structures that
exist and the way that Fame and and and
money affect the process yeah it's not
only Fame and money I also think like
you going to filter yourself like how I
view in the scientific community and
because you're not anonymous I think
it's provide like some structure of like
Oh am I considered credential enough if
I'm considering my like you what like
other scientific community think about
me so I don't know what's the best way
to deploy this but I think there is an
interesting like gap that we should like
felt in terms of from watching a lot of
like independent and also anonymous
researchers you think about how many
young people have incredible ideas that
they want to uplift into more of a
mainstream edge of science but they
can't because they don't have the
credentials the background these types
of questions and how to rethink the
structures to make it easier for someone
that's in their later part of their life
earlier part of their life to get
involved in pushing the edge of science
so you spent a decent amount of time
also with self teaching as well so teach
us about how you ended up self teaching
yourself I think a lot of people are
really interested in this
like this whole unschooling process so
it teaches about that yes I guess very
related to that one idea I want to talk
it's like a scientific community that
we're going to like how is important to
structure a lot more after some
scientific community that essentially
helps me a lot I guess when I moved I
kind of like know that I want to like
again Nick the question is like there's
a separate question like whatever can a
scale scientific community or not but
like one of the things I learned them
more suck when I moved to the Bay Area I
was working to start up but then I
involving like leaving my class of
community houses and this community
houses like I was also like I was taught
like people I have like a secret master
at Stanford because I was going to like
lots of classes like as Stanford and
going to confront us like that helps me
a lot I feel like they should be like I
school that like you don't pay tuition
you just for like one year the skirts
like conferences because like you learn
a lot of you know what like like this
thing has like a feel and what you learn
and that doesn't like affect me a lot
like figuring out asking more important
the questions or like figuring what's
the most relevant resources that I need
to like use or like people that like
help me along the way and also at the
classes at Stanford Berkeley MIT or just
walk in yeah
we chose like very great because like
lots of you actually like my housemate
was like TA one of the NLP class and so
he was like his yet 11 p.m. can nobody
go see is here knock his is like can I
ask you a question okay take that class
yes but I think so like lots of people
like putting courses online but also
creating aikido's community for learning
it's very important I wish it was in all
the cities like around the world like we
kind of see there was like here also
there is lots of really cool science
community houses like I wish like we see
a lot more around the world that people
come together and learn together and
even they create their own directions
they can like use like lots of resources
like as part of what they are working on
and I think that's something you see a
lot in second where there's like lots of
like people with weird background that's
not common in other places usually and
that's something I like to see a lot
more in scientific community that
potential helps a lot also those other
things I did like the first research
project I have I met people I worked
with like very weirdly like one of them
was one of my friend I met at Burning
Man and we are talking about AI and we
had talked for like eight hours or
something like that and then after we
just like okay we should like probably
work on decorating paper and I find the
mentor that he also like how fast like
it was a great established scented like
scientist and like someone else it was
like under God in a meeting we kind of
form like a independent research like
project that we work together which is
like none of us has like a credential by
académica Stan that we see except a
mentor that I find you and I was like
really fulfilling a commitment that I
had like that you can do it it's like a
lot harder but it was kind of like
possible that you can structure the way
to like discover the ideas that you want
and that kind of fact made me a lot more
interested to to like research in a high
and that's something I continue doing
that and I were
collaborated opening I and also I was I
structure at Udacity so those because of
just I made like my own like science
research project and I find it kind of
people and work with them what's up yeah
that's how to funnel yourself into
organizations that are doing good work
and learn from their processes and also
I like how you explain that there's
totally for for young people a finding
finding mentors is so critical
walking into conferences volunteering at
conferences networking with people at
conferences
also walking into classes finding these
little sign these pockets of like
scientific houses where people are
living together pushing a specific edge
in a field I I look forward to society
having more of these pockets of like
scientific houses and like conference
tours for young people to like go around
in just like going to classes and
singing classes and like take lectures
but they don't do this so I'm freshly
there very few people I see like they're
coming to Casa snapper and whenever you
ask professors they're like fine and you
could see them I confess to go can I sit
your classic you're fine sure yeah
especially when you want to because they
already have students in their class
that don't the pay and don't even want
to be there to you like it yeah and then
you can also like do the side project in
the class because the main important
part also act doing hot that assignment
so you can find the email and you're all
of a sudden you're going up there yeah
you're one of their star pupils because
you actually care about the class yeah I
mean for some further a lot like harder
harder as you make friends for example
you trying to do like vet biology labs I
think that's why we require to have hubs
that are make those sorts of experiments
are much more feasible there is also the
other interesting things we should talk
about is like the whole aspect of
feedback loop in order to do like
research I think one of the things in AI
the feedback loop is shirt I mean
there's some downside that we see like
lots of very small incremental change
but also because the computing former we
had
in past recent years make everyone easy
to like run the experiment and kind of
like deploy like like lots of algorithms
that we see and kind of flag do modify
and do engineering over because that
feedback loop is like very very short
when you change like one your algorithms
and like test it but some felt if you
don't have really good benchmark and V
the feedback is really really long like
for example if you want to like do the
test on my case that kind of like BC iff
like longitudinal tests have a long
feedback that's like I'll just push that
we just keep pushing we don't even like
the longitudinal test it's like yeah
that ten-year test act just pushed the
technology into society forget the
ten-year time there are so many like
with no idea how these technology
devices are actually affecting our visit
the physiology of our neurology like we
don't actually really know yet we're
only starting to understand a little bit
yeah but also I think the question if
you want to push that edge be sure to
kind of think about like laws and
regulations and then bringing down the
feedback loop especially for example if
you want to a quirk with PCI or like
hybrid like computing such like
intelligence I'm prepared so I think for
those I could be really required to have
or in the feedback sure the feedback the
better benchmark and different
resolutions also we need the need for
independent independent researchers I
totally agree and actually that kind of
leads us to you're directing Shanon labs
to although I would say I really think
about ethics and ethical consequences
and that's like a whole sets of things
like it should be think about when
you're designing the process and
probably I think a huge part of it but
also like you said just making
regulations smoother for scientific
discovery making shorter feedback loops
and and but at the same time also
recognizing that if we if we don't run
longitudinal tests we can have more oops
moments so
so um another aspect everything
scientific discoveries what you're doing
with Shannon labs yeah go ahead were you
so much Shannon labs like I because I
mentioned to you like the first like
magic I spend that myself was like
finding the kind of researchers and
working through that like process
because I study like random major
sociology and like leadership just
because of the practical reason the fear
that I went through my life but then
when I started this one I see how the
process really hard like it wasn't like
really scalable finding the mentor that
finding I was kind of was able like
nobody take me like so you stay when I
was like trying to like do science I go
you're not technical you don't know this
I know this one so the whole process was
like a lot harder and I wanted to kind
of [ __ ] make a fellowship that provide
mentorship and funding and other types
of Lake system we were thinking where we
talk about for people are come from some
sort of unconventional like background
or like they trying to think about
science and they have like or that they
are trying to merge different
disciplines or return to work on like
benchmark and that like no one really
care about or like shorting me a
feedback loop or they want to be an
enormous and they want to like work on
like stuff like directions that they
don't have like enough support network
so they want to say there goes like
finding news like like a sets of ideas
and people and like project that there
are not really fit in exactly in the
current mechanism or disciplines of like
academic Institute that we have and
finding them not necessarily like
potentially maybe MIT Media Lab is like
a really interesting like science hub
but that's like very one specific
locations that is like one place right
and like other places like very like
structuring like when you have people
all in the world like hi chain kind of
creating
community and supporting equipment
that's a great goal of sectional labs be
finding those projects and people
innovating science you know and you
highlighted the word independent
researcher it seems to be another more
and more important thing to do is to not
funnel ourselves into necessarily the
the constraints of academia or the
constraints of corporations and industry
but stay independent how do we fund
independent researchers more effectively
and let them pursue what they're
treating as their inputstream lawyer are
they finding profound realizations and
what are they outputting with that
because it's usually really novel and
important for our world although I think
as I mentioned academic institutions
they have lots of benefits totally we
should break about the mentorship that
you have the way you can make a
structure you can still get that
mentorship independently as well it's
harder to restructure and that's one of
the Golf Channel apps that we have
because like the mentorship that you
want to find independent it's just a lot
harder and it's like depends on the
stage of your career for example if
you're like already well established
that put in check NIH for example
recently opened up the grants for
independent researchers but the one that
our Pro Stock like level they already
like go through like be some sort of
like a professorships or whatever but
they want to like work on like
somebody's that independently and they
give them like lots of funding to work
on this direction but they're like a lot
more competitive in order to get there
and also you should have some sort of
credit creations that we like to talk
about being independent it has some
downsides and some like you always like
need to worry about funding you always
need to worry about mentorship and if
you can provide those support networks
then my hope is like we running up a lot
with more in the
pendant and another almost potentially
researchers yeah that's huge that's huge
the funding the mentorship for
independent researchers to deploy more
anonymous selfless updates into our
world to rethink scientific discovery in
general let's ask a couple quick
questions on the way out that we like to
ask our guests what are your thoughts on
what happens before birth and after
death before breath and after this I
think it's just about okay one thing is
super interesting you can consider what
is consciousness come from and the
consciousness come from potentially like
evolving some sort of psychic complexity
in the system that we are going to see
so before Beth we are and also like a
souls that we have is kind of like a one
like system with some like rules and it
kind of like like you feeling all the
energy from your like mom into like a
low complexity like sauce and that star
like replicating and that provides like
some consciousness patterns which that
would be very very interesting I guess
like before earth like a conscious
patterns wasn't exist in essence from my
perspective because it's kind of this
energy level doesn't follow like
particles or doesn't have any sort of
like a lower entropy so we just like
seeing I think one thing is an artistry
interesting like you always see the
intersections of like changing like
things to like lower to higher entropy
in your system and before battery
potentially didn't have dual or entropy
or genetic mutations that we have and
then after that yeah I think what is
important that we
working in something is important that
those are those ideas to stay because
that's kind of part of agricultural
revolutions I can have her like the
ideas that like contrary about the next
phase in our timeline but I don't think
we are as a person with like we exist do
you think we're alone in the cosmos we
are alone in the cosmos as a human
species or as a intelligence creature
you take it wherever you want as
intolerance creature I don't think so I
think there is a chance of like having
life in universes like relatively high
there's a good like equations like my
conclusions that talks about that and
the other and ya know so I don't Frank
in his book it's he should invite him
there
he's also a very interesting like their
life affects civilizations on earth is
like talking about the chance of like
you have in the civilization so I think
that sec exists but as a humanist fishes
there might be us on earth and that
exists but as an individual person I
think every person is alone in the
universe and they create their own like
force 21 ideas about the universe but be
all like influencing on each other and
do you think we're in a simulation we're
in the simulation
I think yeah we are in a simulation we
like some sort of like a shared reality
among lots of us that we are evolving
and we should kind of like a scope out a
lot more like to have better perspective
of like what directions after simulation
that we can imagine that we don't
imagine right now it would let me live
the trajectory of where the civilization
goes yeah to envision and understand
actions we need to take in order to get
to the good outcomes do you what do you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world most beautiful things I think I'm
very interested in the relationship
between entropy and complexity and time
yeah and I think that is like something
create life that is great like many
different patterns that is great
intelligence and that something I think
is very most beautiful there's like
relationships yeah that's beautiful I
love that too all right
party this has been super fun thank you
for coming on to the show yeah
good I'm glad to hear that you sank you
to everyone for tuning in and watching
the greatly appreciate love to hear your
thoughts and comments below in the
episode also going to talk more to your
friends your co-workers family people
online on social media about rethinking
scientific discovery have more
conversations about it
cue shout out to Round of August for
producing and directing thank you very
much Ronnie and go and check out the
links of the bio to Shannon lab so also
parties Twitter and check out
simulations links help support us
support us help us grow and prosper and
also support the artists entrepreneurs
the organizations in your communities
and go and build the future everyone
manifest those dreams into the world
thanks for tuning in and we'll see you
soon these
[Music]
[Music]